Hello. I'm Victor Lee,
vice president of
machine learning
and AI at TigerGraph,
and I'm here today to talk to
you about graph algorithms and
graph machine learning,
making sense of
today's choices.
So what is graph
machine learning?
You may have heard
several things
about it. Of course,
we start with
graph algorithms,
knowledge graphs,
which have both
been around for
a long time. Now we hear about
graph data science,
graph embeddings,
graph neural networks.
Maybe you know what these team
terms mean. Maybe they're less
familiar to you.
But even if you know them,
how do they all fit together?
What are the use cases?
How should you
orchestrate these
into some real
world use cases?
So we're gonna
be going through
some questions in this talk.
Does graph machine learning
replace graph algorithms?
What is a graph embedding?
What's the difference between
graph neural networks and
conventional neural networks?
What are the use
cases for these
methods? And lastly,
what setup do I need to run
graph machine learning?
These, we hope,
are maybe some
of the questions
that you have, and we'll be
addressing them in this talk.
So the first thing to remember
is that there's more than one
type of machine learning.
So first of all,
we have unsupervised
machine learning,
which is very data driven.
You you just look at
the data you have,
and you run some automated,
analytics to try to uncover
interesting things,
relevant things,
characteristic of that data.
You're not you don't know what
you're looking for.
You just let the data
itself tell you.
And graph algorithms
are an excellent
example of unsupervised
learning.
So in that way,
graph algorithms
apply to machine
learning. Then
there's supervised.
When people talk about ML,
they're actually
usually talking
about supervised learning,
particularly deep learning and
neural networks.
And so there's usually some,
particular aim,
like you're trying to make
predictions based on
some existing data.
It's tied to
classify objects.
If I if I don't know what type
of thing this is,
can I use previous examples to
develop a a model?
Think of decision trees.
Decision trees are an example
of of a model which classifies
something. You answer
some questions,
yes or no, and it eventually
gives you an answer
and says, oh,
you are this type of thing or
you should do this.
It's it's putting
you into a class
and learning what well,
what are the questions you we
should ask in
the decision tree.
Sometimes you use
machine learning
for that. And
there's reinforcement
learning. That's when you just
try a task and
you're gonna make
mistakes, but you learn from
those mistakes,
and eventually,
you learn how to do
it really well.
So graph can apply both to
unsupervised and
supervised and
and reinforcement.
We're gonna focus primarily on
supervised learning
in this talk.
It's also good to
look at a typical
pipeline or workflow for doing
machine learning because this
will tell us at
what stages and
in what ways graph can help.
So first of all,
at the beginning,
when you're just
gathering your
data and assembling it,
you made a a decision,
presumably,
to model it as a graph.
Since we're talking
about graph
machine learning,
we've gotta start
off with a graph.
So if you've made the decision
that the relationships,
the connections that you can
express in a graph
are that added,
density of information,
I call it.
So more understanding
how things
are connected to each other is
often what you're
trying that's
the nature of
understanding data.
And so, that's
the first way it
contributes. The
second is kinda
cleaning up your data,
making sure that things are
represented in
a standard way,
representing things that,
might appear as
different objects
in the original
data are in fact
the same real world object.
That's entity resolution.
Trying to find those,
making those matches of of
different identities that are
in fact the same.
You can use graph
based techniques
for that.
And when here in the middle,
this is the core
section where,
traditionally,
graph has played
a role in machine learning.
Using graph based
features either
through either
through standard
algorithms or writing specific
pattern matching queries that
that you designed for for your
application. And
this is all in
the data preparation phase.
And then we get to
the model training.
And and this is model training
is when people
talk about machine
learning. That's, again,
usually what they're
thinking about.
And now we have graph neural
networks where if you
have graph data,
you can train directly on that
using a graph neural network.
So we'll talk about that.
And then we have
graph embedding.
And and, again,
that's one of the terms we're
gonna define, and
I've intentionally
put it in between feature
extraction and model training
because it has
aspects of both.
So we have answered the first
of our questions.
Does graph machine learning
replace graph algorithms? No.
It doesn't because
they contribute
in different ways.
Graph algorithms
are great during
the the feature extraction and
feature engineering phase.
They can also be used during
the the data cleansing phase.
But then you use graph machine
learning is really
the whole scope.
But if you wanted to think of
it as just the graph
neural networks,
then that is a a later stage
that comes after you probably
use the graph algorithms.
So then looking at
that pipeline,
we saw about four stages where
graph can can contribute.
So we're gonna talk about each
of those phases.
The first being graph assisted
data cleansing and
entity resolution.
So one thing that graphs are
really good at is
is identifying
how things can be similar.
And in this sense,
let's talk about this.
In this example,
we have persons represented by
these larger orange
vertices, person a,
person b.
And then features
or characteristics
of them are
represented by these
blue vertices.
And think about,
say, x might
represent a school,
a particular school,
And this relationship means
person a went to school x,
and this means person b also
went to school x.
So they have
something in common.
We y might be a city they grew
up in or a place
where they work.
Other things they
have in common.
And so there's a reason why
these are because,
a city or a school
are entities
in themselves.
That's why they're
represented as vertices
in the graph.
And so there are a variety of
similarity algorithms that can
be used to compute
a score based
on this graph
structural similarity
of a and b.
One example is
cosine similarity.
It takes into
account the weights
of these relationships
and which
ones match. And
so the score is
gonna depend on the weights of
these x and y
that match, but,
divided by
the existence of all
these other factors
whether they
match or not.
That's one way to
come up with a score.
And once you have
these scores,
you can represent
them on the graph.
And this means
that, this group,
they all have
similarity scores
in the nineties.
This group, they also have
similarity scores
in the nineties,
but c to e is only
sixty five percent,
d to f is only sixty percent.
So those are lower.
We can then do some
scores together.
If these each
represent persons,
that may mean of these seven
original digital identities,
we've reduced them or resolved
them to two real
world identities,
Barry Markham and
Beryl Markham.
So that is,
one way that we can use graph
for machine learning.
Another way is to help develop
graph based features
using either
algorithms or
pattern matching.
And there are lots and lots of
graph algorithms.
This is TigerGraph's current
graph algorithm library with
about fifty algorithms,
but they're even more.
So we're always
developing more.
And they each have
their different uses.
The first thing
you wanna do is
understand the general type.
Is it the similarity
algorithm?
Is it a centrality algorithm?
Is it a community algorithm?
And then there are different
varieties among those.
And then they
those all lead to
different uses.
So here's just one example.
And say you're
trying to do some,
data preprocessing
to help predict,
fraud. And so in this data,
we have different application
programs and then
which have personal,
identifying information.
So this is your
private information,
which you don't
want unauthorized
persons to see.
And by informing this graph,
we can see that there's
a cluster here,
and there's a cluster here.
And so and then
we we apply a a
community detection algorithm
like Louvain. And then we move
on to the next step when we
apply other graph
algorithms to
each of these communities
to score them,
so to speak. So we
have page rank.
We have, LCC,
another community
detection algorithm,
and diameter estimation,
which has to do with, like,
what are the shortest paths to
get from anywhere
to anywhere.
So the diameter
is the so called
worst of the shortest paths
toward the longest
of the shortest
paths. So we come
up with an average
page rank score,
an average LCC score,
and the diameter of each of
these components.
And you see, like excuse me.
These scores, you
can think of,
they're numeric,
and there's a set of them,
and you can put them
in a particular
order. And, hey,
that's a feature vector.
So you now have
a feature vector
to describe this community.
You can then put that into,
machine learning algorithm to
train it to detect
which communities
represent ones with fraud and
which ones not.
Because fraud tends to happen
fraud is an interaction
activity.
You don't do fraud
in isolation.
It's always
somebody interacting
with somebody else.
That's just one example.
This was taken from
a presentation
that one of my
colleagues presented.
So if you wanna
find out more,
you can find other use cases
from this presentation.
It's not always
standard algorithms,
but sometimes it's
it's designated
pattern matching queries that
you wrote for a specific
application.
In this application,
we have phones and phone calls
between the phones
to form a graph.
And the the phone
service provider,
the telephone company,
is trying to do some automated
real time detection to see if
the phone call
is is from an an
annoying unwanted
caller, a spammer,
somebody who is,
you know or maybe running some
kind of scam.
And so we extract
we design several.
In this case, several
means a hundred
and eighteen different pattern
queries such as,
is there a pattern
that's a a four
hop loop?
Is there a pattern of calls to
people who were
called frequently
over a certain time window?
Is there a pattern
of people who
were called and then call each
other forming
a little subcommunity
within a certain time window.
And each of these features
produces a score.
Maybe it's yes, no.
Maybe it's it's how often that
pattern occurs.
And so you get
a feature vector.
And then using that
feature vector,
we can, again,
train it to detect
in which cases,
are these is this caller,
the hub caller,
caller number one,
the source caller,
somebody who might
be a spammer
or a scammer. So that's
the second way.
Again, graph can help us with
data cleansing.
Graph can help
us with the very
important phase of
feature engineering.
And now we're starting
to get into,
getting into machine learning
traditionally thought of,
and into the the model
building.
So one of the challenges with
graph machine learning is that
the data is so rich.
It expresses such a wealth of
information that
sometimes doing
this analytics can
be expensive.
And, also,
conventional machine
learning techniques are based
on matrices, not on graphs.
So there's a difference
in the data
representation, and there may
be too much information to
conveniently handle.
So enter embeddings
as a possible
solution. What is
an embedding?
That was one of
our questions.
An embedding transforms high
dimensional data into
a lower dimension.
An everyday example is how do
we represent our
spherical Earth,
our planet on a map?
We all read two
dimensional maps,
but the world is
three-dimensional.
A local map seems
not a problem
because the the Earth
is relatively
flat in that small space.
But when you look at
the whole globe,
we have squashed
the globe onto
a flat projection.
And that projection
is an embedding
that is a transform from three
d to two d. And
so you preserve
the important details.
You may have, you know,
have some error in
some of the less
important details.
And you can see here examples
of three different ways to map
the the world onto
a flat surface.
So in the case of a graph,
what we wanna do is we start
with the original graph.
We take into account
all the edges,
the structural relationship of
the graph, but we wanna reduce
that down till we just have
individual vertex vectors.
So if these are the,
the seven vertices
plus their edges,
we now just have
these seven rows,
and each row
produces a a vector
of latent features.
They're not features that you
can really describe,
but a key is that this is
relatively compact.
And so now we have
tabular data,
which is relatively compact,
makes it amenable
to traditional
machine learning.
And the the characteristic of
these embeddings
is that if two
vertices have are structurally
similar because
they connect to
similar things in
the in the same
quantity, with
the same similar
types of paths, the same
type of things,
then they will have
similar vectors.
You can use simple algorithms
that compute the similarity
between two vectors,
like cosine similarity,
and you can make
recommendations.
You can group them together if
they're similar and
do classification.
So you can do
fraud detection.
Again, all the use cases that
we had before, you
can still apply.
But we've transformed
the data.
We've made it more scalable.
We've made it more compact,
and we've made it tabular,
which means that you can now
apply traditional
machine learning
techniques. So, again,
why you do it?
So to get a dense
tabular format,
and to gather graph features
without manual
extraction. Oops.
And is it suitable?
It's it's better if your data
is relatively
stable because if
the data changes,
you will have to retrain it.
So this answers our
second question,
what is a graph embedding?
It's something that transforms
this graph structure
into a compressed
tabular format.
And we're now on
to the the fourth
way that graph can help with
with machine learning,
and that is graph
neural networks
themselves. And start with
ordinary neural networks,
a powerful machine learning
technique to predict
and classify.
That's why they're
so well known,
so well used.
And then we have graph,
which is a great way to get
insight through
connected data.
You can somehow
combine these.
You can get what
we call a graph
convolutional neural network.
So you take the traditional,
neural network data flow,
and you insert an additional
step called the graph
convolution.
And what the graph convolution
is doing is if each of these
nodes represents
a vertex in the graph,
and so we're trying to learn
about each each
vertex in the graph.
We have a convolution
step where
we take its features,
this vertices features,
and combine it
with the features
of its neighbors.
And maybe maybe
it's an averaging.
Maybe it's something a little
more complicated
than averaging.
But in some way,
you combine and or convolve,
as they say,
the features of this
with its neighbors.
And that's where the graph
information is coming in,
looking at neighbors.
So combines the added insight
from connected data
with the modeling
power of neural networks.
And so you're actually using
the graph structure
doing during
the training. It's not
just a preprocessing
step, but it's
you actually use
the graph during
the training cycle.
The basic one we talked about
is for a so called homogeneous
graph when there's
only one type
of node, one type of edge.
If you're familiar with other
types of graph neural network
other types of neural networks
like attention networks or
recurrent networks,
There are graph
versions of those.
There are also algorithms for
heterogeneous graphs
where there's
more than one type of node and
more than one type of edge.
And what's better,
there are now,
three major open
source GNN libraries.
All, PyTorch has one.
TensorFlow just
introduced one.
And there's one DGL
deep graph learning,
which is just for graph.
And so you have
several choices
for open source libraries,
all in all in
Python, of course.
And so why would
you use a graph
neural network?
If you have a graph
where graph
structure is important and you
have a task where
a neural network
makes sense, then you probably
should consider using graph or
neural network.
So you don't need
to explicitly
extract graph features.
The training will do that.
As I've said, they're they're
a well established
software framework,
because you're
you're just using
a neural network.
It's in Python.
You can use a lot
of the the same
infrastructure. And so that
answers one more question,
and we'll we'll sort of say
what's the difference between
a graph neural network
and a conventional
neural network.
It's that convolution
phase when
you're taking the local graph
structure into account during
the training. And I said,
we're just gonna say,
we've talked about
some use cases.
There are lots of use cases.
Don't have time to get
into all of them.
But, again, if if you
have graph data,
you can apply these.
You're gonna get
some benefit.
The last question we're gonna
look at is what setup do you
need for graph
machine learning?
Learning. And here it's useful
to again look at
our pipeline.
So first off,
you're gonna want
a graph database
and, hopefully,
a scalable one to to make sure
it's large enough
and performant
enough for the task
you need to do.
Because you're gonna be doing
some computationally
complex or
intense stuff.
To do the data cleansing,
you're gonna have
to be able to
do some queries and updates.
So you wanna be
able to, you know,
update your data
in the graph.
And you're gonna need a graph
algorithm library
as well as a graph
query language.
You know, all databases come
with a graph query language,
but you want them which is
flexible enough
to express some
of those patterns
such as the one
in that, unwanted phone call
application we looked at.
And lastly, you
need the capability
to run graph neural networks.
So where are you
gonna get these
capabilities? Oh, one more.
Graph embedding also.
So all of these are or should
be available within
a database.
Obviously, this
is a database,
and you wanna be
updating the data
in the database.
So, ideally, you
can, run queries,
update, read, read,
write, read,
modify, write queries here.
And in this phase,
you want a graph
algorithm library
incorporated in your database
as well as, you know,
a graph query
language can also
extract custom features.
For this last phase
of model building,
you know, traditionally,
you would export your data to
machine learning server,
but it's becoming more common
that customers are looking for
in database machine learning.
And why would they do that?
It's because it simplifies and
shortens the pipeline.
You bring the data in.
You do your
feature engineering
and data cleansing
in database.
You train in in in database.
You deploy in database.
So there's, you
don't have the the
time and expense
of pushing data
from one place to
around to another,
it becomes a much more data
centered operation.
You you bring the analytics to
the database
rather than moving
the data moving
the data in a physical
pipeline. And so last,
I think that that
covers all of
our points. So let's
let's review.
So graph machine learning and
graph algorithms contribute in
different and
complementary ways
to analytics and
machine learning.
So it's not an either
or choice.
What is a graph embedding?
It's something that transforms
the graph structure
to a a more
compressed and tabular format
for compatibility,
with more traditional
machine learning.
Or you can do graph
neural networks,
and you actually
can use both,
but probably you would either
use a graph embedding
with a traditional
neural network or
a graph neural
network. And a graph neural
network takes local graph
structure into account during
the training. And lastly,
if you wanna take advantage of
all of this, you're gonna need
a scalable graph database with
flexible graph querying and
doing those read
write updates.
You're gonna need a graph
algorithm library and either
an internal or external graph
machine learning library with
the advantages of
of in database
machine learning where you can
do the training
in the database,
are starting to
become apparent.
And, again, we we hit on a few
use cases. There's
so many more.
So I'll just say they abound.
And so thank you very much for
your your attention, and I,
hope you got something
out of this talk.
Thank you very much.